welcome to bananamores i'm so excited to
watch this next performer light up
the bananamore stage get ready for
comedy greatness
wow bananamores thank you mitzi thank
you
it's an honor to be here um really you
know quarantine is crazy
right guaranteed the craziest thing
about it though
is is everybody's corn team
everybody's quarantined y'all think
about that everybody
morgan freeman is quarantining right now
narrating to himself 6 a.m
i wake up the sun glistens
through my blinds 10 am i go to the
couch like i did yesterday
and the day before that and the day
before that
and the day before that
10 35 a.m i passed gas
softly into the plush sofa cushions
you've heard of the bars of the penguins
but that was the fart
of the freedom
i spent too much time thinking about
celebrities in their mansions right now
i'm i'm in my tiny north hollywood
apartment for the last year and a half
will smith is in some wing of his house
going
oh man
oh damn where am i
no for real uh well i'm lost in my own
place
i took a wrong turn at the 37th bathroom
oh i'm sitting around miserable in
sweatpants every day
wow cat williams is in a diamond-studded
silk
robe just never in the history of
copendom
has a pimp ever quarantined with this
much bling okay
listen lockdown is a mess it's straight
doo doo boo boo
he just sips from a gold chalice
just a goblet with a pinky ring for a
handle
it's crazy i'm excited though i'm
excited to get out there you know i
can't wait to get the vaccine
i heard jb smooth got vaccinated yeah
yeah he was like
you'll see i couldn't get the cover 19
vaccine yeah black people get the covert
45 vaccine it's just a shot that you
have to put in a brown paper bag
okay that's my time thank you so much
mitzi thank you so much for this
this opportunity i can't even get over
how much talent this person has it's
great to be here
love you you're beautiful all right that
comedian knows how to work a
crowd am i right